Harry Kersh: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Domino's pizza
in the UK and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
This is the smallest pizza
you can get in the UK.
It's called an individual,
and it measures 7 inches across.
Joe Avella: Our smallest is,
believe it or not, this small.
Here it is, and it measures
in diameter 10 inches.
Harry: The next size up is a small,
which measures 9.5 inches.
Joe: Next size up for
the US is our medium,
which is 12 inches.
Harry: This is 11.5 inches.
Joe: What? I'm starving.
Hey, I grabbed a slice.
I'm starving. This pizza smells so good.
I skipped breakfast.
Next pizza.
Next up for the US is our large,
which is a 14-inch diameter.
Oh, hell, yeah.
What's with the way they
cut your large pizza, Harry?
It's ridiculous. Look at that.
And not to be outdone,
the US has one more size, the extra large.
Diameter, 16 inches. Bro!
Look at the size of this thing.
Harry: Now, a 2.5-inch difference
might not sound like a lot,
but if you factor that
into the surface area,
it's actually 58 square inches wider
than the UK's largest pizza,
which is almost a third of an increase.
Joe: Am I looking at this right?
Is it supposed to be six slices?
It's six slices. That can't be right.
Six slices for a extra-large pizza?
Look at the size of these slices!
In the US at a Domino's,
the extra-large pizza will cost you
a very reasonable $13.99.
Hm.
That...circle....
That is 201 square inches,
which breaks down to roughly
7 cents an inch?
Nice.
Harry: Now, shockingly,
$13.99 will only get you
a small pizza in the UK.
A small pizza is 9.5 inches across,
and that gives it a surface
area of 71 square inches.
Now, if you divide the
$13.69 price tag by the 71,
you find out that you're actually paying
19 cents per square inch.
Ultimately, it means that
if you went into a US
and a UK Domino's with $13.99 to spend,
you'd be able to get more
than double the pizza
for your money in the US store.
Let's compare large cheese
pizzas in the two countries.
This is what a UK large cheese looks like.
Joe: And this is what a large,
properly cut Domino's cheese
pizza looks like in the US.
Harry: It's cut into 10 pieces,
and each slice contains 176 calories.
That means that in total,
the pizza in the UK is 1,760 calories.
Joe: Instead of 10, we got eight slices.
That means each slice
is roughly 280 calories,
which makes the whole
pizza 2,240 calories.
And according to the thing
that was written for me,
that is almost 480 calories
more than the UK large.
Harry: But why is that exactly?
Let's see if we can get any
clues from the ingredients.
Let's start with the
foundation of any pizza,
which is the dough.
In the UK, the dough
is made of wheat flour,
a wheat and milk premix,
rapeseed oil, water, and yeast.
Joe: Yes, but here in the US,
our dough is made of...
enriched flour, wheat -
oh, God, I hate reading this stuff.
Enriched flour, which
is wheat flour, iron,
thiamine mononitrate, niacin, riboflavin,
and folic acid, water, soybean oil.
And it contains less
than 2% of the following:
sugar, salt, whey,
maltodextrin, dextrose,
dough conditioners such as
sodium stearoyl lacksi...
lactylate.
I don't know. It's on the screen.
You read it out loud.
Enzymes! Calcium sulfate,
ascorbic acid, calcium phosphate,
L-cysteine. Good for hangovers, I hear.
Yeast and cornmeal.
Uh, yeah, much different.
A lot more chemicals.
Who saw that coming? [laughs]
Harry: How about the cheese?
Domino's in the UK refers to its cheese
simply as mozzarella, and it's mostly
because the ingredients are just that.
Joe: In the US, Domino's
doesn't - possibly can't -
call their cheese mozzarella.
Instead, they refer to
it as "pizza cheese."
So, the Domino's in
the US's "pizza cheese"
has the following ingredients.
Part-skim mozzarella cheese, OK,
which is pasteurized milk,
cultures, salt, enzymes,
modified food starch,
cellulose, nonfat milk,
whey protein concentrate, natural flavors,
and sodium proponiate.
Prop-io-nate.
Propionate.
Harry: Now let's look at the pepperoni.
Most of the ingredients
in US and UK pepperoni
are actually pretty similar.
They both contain pork, salt, dextrose,
spices, sodium nitrite, citric acid,
flavorings, and starter culture.
Joe: You know, the only difference is
that our pepperoni contains beef.
Also preservatives
beutohydrolate, hydrolazinase,
and beautohadalid blabbity blah.
BHA and BHT.
I can't pronounce them.
They're bad. [laughs]
Harry: It turns out BHA
and BHT are actually
subject to restrictions
in the European Union
and can't be added to
foods such as pepperoni.
This might be because studies have shown
that BHA can cause tumors in rats
and is therefore reasonably anticipated
to be a carcinogen in humans.
Joe: Oh, well.
I'm gonna die doing what I love.
Eating banned chemicals. Mm!
Harry: We reached out to
Domino's to get some clarity
on the pepperoni situation.
We got our info from
their ingredients webpage.
However, when we checked with them,
they told us that their
information was incorrect,
and they've updated it
since to say that BHA
and BHT have now been
removed from the pepperoni.
I think this happened at
some point during 2018.
They couldn't say exactly when.
But, Joe, it sounds like
you're OK after all.
Here are all the items you can only find
on the menu at a UK Domino's.
Joe: And here are all the
things you can only get
at a US Domino's.
Harry: Let's start with the pizza itself.
So, firstly is the crust options.
Now, in the UK, we can
actually get stuffed crust.
But what we've gone for here
is the Italian-style crust.
Apologies to the country
of Italy for this one.
Now, the Italian crust is
basically the same dough
but just thinner and
therefore a bit more crispy.
There are a few toppings
that you can only get
on your pizza in the UK.
These include some options we've got here,
like meatballs, sweet corn, and red onion.
But that's not all.
You can also get things
like Catalan chicken,
which is a chicken in a
kind of paprika spice.
You can get tandoori chicken,
which is chicken with
some Indian spice blends.
And you can also get tuna on your pizza.
Joe: Whoa, wait.
Did he say tuna? Tuna on a pizza?
No, no way.
So, this right here is a pizza that has
everything you can only
get at a US Domino's.
First of all, the crust.
It is our thin Brooklyn-style crust.
Instead of tomato sauce, we
did an Alfredo white sauce.
We got banana peppers on here,
salami, feta cheese, and
also Parmesan and cheddar.
This should be known as The US Only.
Like, Pizza Hut should
have this on the menu,
and you go, "Give me The US Only."
And this is the pizza they give you.
Yuck. Don't get this.
[laughing]
Yeah, I hate that.
Grab a slice. See what you think.
Harry: So, here are some UK sides
that you won't find on
the menu at a US Domino's.
First of all, we've got
the garlic cheesy bread.
Chicken Kickers, which are just, like,
nuggets with a spicy coating.
Pretty recently, they've added these
Pop'n Chicken bites to the menu,
which, kind of similar
to KFC's popcorn chicken.
You can also get Chicken Strippers,
which is just kind of
like chicken tenders.
Potato wedges, if you wanted
some kind of potato option
to go with your pizza,
and then you can also
get a tub of coleslaw.
Joe: I don't think we
have garlic cheesy bread,
but we do have this, which is
like a stuffed cheese bread.
Also, this side, they
have these chicken pieces,
and then, these right over here,
these Parmesan cheese kind of bread knots.
[crunching]
Also I think it's pretty
cool, is Domino's will
hook you up with a side
of grated Parmesan.
That's pretty nice.
Chicken carbonara, which is a pasta dish,
but looks like obviously chicken,
bits of bacon, onion.
In the US, Domino's
offers a lot of different
varieties of sandwiches.
I just picked one.
I got the chicken Parm sandwich.
Let's take a look at that right there.
Look at that chicken Parm.
How good does that look?
Classic garden salad.
We found something green
on the menu, which is nice.
What do we got here? Tomatoes, onions,
cheese, lettuce, croutons.
[sighs] Who cares?
Harry: Now, the default
dipping sauce that will come
with your pizzas is this
garlic and herb dip in the UK.
But there are also a couple of sauces
which are exclusive to the UK.
These include a little pot
of Frank's RedHot sauce,
and we can also get a honey mustard.
Joe: The Domino's in the US
has their own exclusive sauces.
This kicker hot sauce, the
sweet mango habanero sauce.
This one is really good.
Ranch. You guys don't have ranch?
Thought you did. Guess not.
Blue cheese dressing, mm.
And, of course, marinara sauce.
Harry: And finally, if you're
someone with a sweet tooth,
Domino's has some exclusive
dessert items in the UK.
Firstly, we've got Domino's cookies,
which are actually, like, really good,
especially if you get
them when they're warm,
and they kind of stay warm
when they rest on the pizza boxes.
And then you can also get a range
of Ben and Jerry's flavors
from Domino's in the UK.
They're, like, a licensed
vendor, which is cool.
Joe: And for dessert in the US,
you can get either these
marbled cookie brownies
or these chocolate lava crunch cakes.
They also throw in this, the sweet icing.
I'm sure it's amazing.
So you can pour more
sugar all over the sugar.
Let's put some icing on that lava guy.
[laughs]
Oh!
That's too much. Stop!
I gotta get, I gotta, I'm gonna,
like, eat this whole tray.
I gotta get this out of my face.
I'm ready to destroy these brownies.